at approximately 10:00 10:00 p.m. last
night the officers of Auburn Police
division responded to the 3000 block of
wire road just outside of Auburn and
report of a domestic situation domestic
disturbance when the officers arrived at
that location they were met by an
individual who was armed with a firearm
that individual did fire upon the
officers three of them were wounded
unfortunately one of the officers was
fatally wounded two others were
seriously injured one of them will be
released the other one is expected to
recover so again three officers were
were injured one of them fatally two
were serious but both of them will be
expected to recover
Grady Wayne wilts a white male suspect
who is 29 years of age last seen armed
and definitely considered dangerous so
we're obviously urging citizens to stay
out of this area until we are able to
take this individual into custody again
we do believe he is dangerous this is
the part of the worst day of my time
here and you know just you know words
cannot express the loss for this family
and our family and this community so you
know we're just going to do everything
we can to bring it to a close
[Music]
and in the background you hear a
helicopter that you know is searching
for a man that investigators believe
shot at least to Auburn officers who
were responding to a domestic
disturbance at a mobile home in the air
ahead and now a massive manhunt is
underway to get this man into custody
before anybody else can get hurt and
again it's all here at the Auburn
complex where again this field was made
for soccer not mobile commands and
brothers and sisters in blue searching
for the man who allegedly shot at least
two of their own that's not what a burn
is and don't forget folks we just had
this happen back in February and thank
God thank God above thank God above
thank God above officer Justin Sanders
is okay thank God above